Abhilash tommy was rescued in one of the
remotest spots on the planet his yacht
capsized and the mass was broken when it
was hit by 40-foot waves in the Indian
Ocean at the weekend Tommy who is also
an officer in the Indian Navy injured
his back and was unable to walk so was
confined to his cabin he was rescued by
a French yacht and stretch it off he has
now been transferred to a bigger
Australian naval ship he's resting in
the sick bay of the ship he is there in
the ship he is at his food he has taken
some water and now he's on to some
medication and he's fine the Golden
Globe race started on the 1st of July
Tommy had been in 3rd position out of 18
competitors before severe storm rolled
his boat 360 degrees and left him
stranded 2,000 miles off the coast of
Western Australia he first issued a Code
Red Alert from his boat on Friday rescue
teams from various nations including
India and Australia had raced towards
him but a French fishing vessel or
Cirrus reached him first he has now been
taken to a French research facility on
Amsterdam Island 60 miles to the north
tommy is one of india's best known
sailors in the golden globe race the
solo competitors have to sail around the
world without the aid of modern
technology our boats are world-class but
they simply don't have a lot of
satellite technology they have to use a
sextant for for navigation purposes but
we have the world's best safety
equipment they're simple boats ordinary
boats but they're special in that
they're well-prepared incredibly strong
and the sailors really do not work what
they're doing you know it's just it's
just one of those things when you go to
sea the race is celebrating its 50th
anniversary this year
it was first won by the Brit robin knox
johnson in 1969 the race has had
previous controversy when a competitor
Donald Crowhurst faked his coordinates
to make it look like he was sailing
around the world when he wasn't he died
towards the end of the race probably
having committed suicide
the Golden Globe race is by invitation
only 10 of the solo competitors have
already pulled out 8 remain including a
British woman Suzy Goodell
the winner will eventually cross the
finish line sometime around February
next year
Alister buckle Sky News